one cross each  it's trying desperately to compensate  right now you look like you need a  handkerchief  i'm sorry  nobody has made any concerted offers to  bribe me yet at all  i've tried bringing you disappointed in  your initiative hello hello hey i'm  going to be using twitter for a week  that's initiative  that's true  hello  hello guys beautiful  whoa  you just confused my camera  all the way down to the booth  it is terrifying walking slowly down  this line  i'm now at 2 minutes and 15 seconds  a word she can't say  recorded for posterity  my sort of vaguely desperate attempt to  record everybody  and we have our danger  definitely danger man  excellent  whoa  just keeps going  something's happened  notice that i'm not there  there we are  more  and i want you to know  it takes exactly five minutes to walk  this line relatively slowly  there we go  um  tom you have a nice loud voice don't you